[музика]
Привіт друзі з вами сьогодні пані Соля і
незабаром доєднається нашу Совеня бо
знову спізнюються давайте ж ми його
погукаємо і дізнаємось чого ж ти зупиняв
знову спізнюєшся приготуємо наші ручки і
гукаємо Совеня
савення
А тепер таким знаєте голосом такого
старого дідуся сова в нього
А тепер голосом маленького кошенятка
сове будеш до совиняє
Я прилетів до вас
Саня Чому ти спізнився
Просто знаєш там таких хмари були великі
і щось трохи вітром мене здувало я ледве
долетів до тебе
Гаразд Совеня ну на цей раз Добре що ти
долетів але будь ласка більше не
спізнюся Домовились
Домовились
До речі класно що ти Совеня розказав
мені про хмарки бо ми будемо сьогодні
говорити про хмарки і не тільки Тож
давайте послухаєш чому в нас в небі
утворюються хмари і тоді будеш знати
домовитись
домовилися я сідаю з бочку і ви друзі
слухайте будь ласка уважно пані солю
Отож друзі Давайте ми з вами поговоримо
про погоду Хто яку погоду любить ось тут
у мене є такий знаєте різні зображення
погоди давайте разом відгадаємо що це за
зображення погоди ось наприклад ось тут
що у нас намальовано
5 сонечко І це яка погода
а тут у нас Що намальовано
хмарки і яка це Погода Так коли хмарно
а тут у нас що мені це дуже нагадує
сніжинки так друзі так і яка це погода
така сніжна колись сніжить так
а тут у нас
дощик намальований Так коли дощить а тут
що це таке може бути якась хвиля
чи єсь волосся намальоване ні А це
вітряно Так ану покажіть як Вітер дує
Ану ще раз
ой друзі ото ви мене здули своїм вітром
Навіть через екран Отож це є вітряна
погода скажіть будь ласка
А яка погода є вашою улюбленою Я
наприклад дуже люблю сонячну погоду а ви
[музика]
супер то давайте будемо продовжувати
далі І зараз ми з вами поговоримо про те
звідки беруться
і у якийсь спосіб у нас з'являється або
зникає якщо справді зникає вода
Гляньте будь ласка на зображення ось тут
Отож Як ви бачите У нас тут є
намальовані різні стрілочки і вони так
наче рухаються по колу стрілочка
стрілочка стрілочка стрілочка що це
означає
А зараз я вам розкажу Отож
Уявіть собі що
зараз випав дощик
і коли ми йдемо на прогулянку після того
як дощик вже припинився що ми бачимо на
асфальті ми бачимо багато
калюж так у яких хочеться застрибнути і
коли виходить Сонечко ми дивимося на
калюжі а їх що нема і ви мабуть думаєте
друзі що ці калюжі просто зникають були
та й не стало а насправді щоб ви знали
мої дорогі жодна вода яку ми бачимо у
вигляді дощу наприклад не зникає нікуди
а просто перетворюється
у інший вид води трохи напевно складно
вам прозвучало але то це дуже просто от
уявіть випаровувались наша калюжа
і Ця вода нікуди не зникає частина з
цієї калюжі і де під низ у ґрунт а
частина
піднімається догори Друзі Ну ви мабуть
Спитаєте пані солю що ти таке кажеш Ну
що в нас підіймається догори я ні разу
не бачу чи не бачила що ви калюжа
піднімалися догори Хіба так буває
молодці не буває я теж так не бачила але
водичка може бути у дуже різних станах
мати дуже різний вигляд і
Відповідно ми не завжди своїми оченятами
можемо побачити де є зараз вода
наприклад У нас є озеро
припустимо і коли на нього світить сонце
частина води з озера випаровується от
знаєте як пара коли в нас чайник копиті
так багато паристає ось Теж У такий
спосіб частина води випаровується І
знаєте куди піднімається
піднімається догори в мене бачимо цієї
водички бо вона є дуже малесенька Але та
вода піднімається догори і
стає хмаркою у який спосіб а в такий що
чим вище ми піднімаємося тим як
холодніше і там малесенька частинка
водички вона стає крижаною тобто
заморожується від того що є дуже холодно
неначе взимку
і перетворюється у хмарки бо
багато-багато маленьких кристаликів
льоду у якій перетворилися вода стоїть
хмаринками їх дуже-дуже багато і ми
відповідно бачимо хмарку пізніше коли
цієї води стає дуже багато
і коли знаєте цю хмарки стають такому
великими вони надзвичайно важкі А знаєте
чому важкі тому що там збираються дуже
багато Водички і коли ці хмарно стають
Ну так ми вважаємо що стається
починає падати дощик або сніг
і коли дощик падає
знову ж таки пам'ятаєте наші калюжі він
нікуди не зникає він просочується у
землю або Освальд і далі у вигляді
різної водички наприклад можна це
назвати ґрунтові води бо вода є в ґрунті
під землею знову
пливе собі до нашого озера чи річки чи
струмочка а частина води випаровується
про що я їм розказувала на початку Ось
так все відбувається по
колу от друзі
Також я вам хочу ще розповісти про те що
крім того що наприклад вода
випаровується з калюж або з річок чи з
озер знати з чого ще випаровується вода
зросла коли дерево дихає а дихають у нас
листочки то частина водички яку ми теж
не бачимо
випаровується до нашої хмарки
Ось така історія Друзі а тепер Давайте
ми з вами зіграємо в одну гру
[музика]
зараз друзі я вам назву
кілька предметів і ваше завдання уважно
слухати та дивитися і сказати мені Який
з цих предметів є зайвим який не
підходить туди Отож Слухайте уважно
дощовик
парасоля
чобітки
сонячні окуляри
дощовик парасоля чобітки сонячні окуляри
що є зайвим
думаємо думаємо думаємо що є зайвим
молодці сонячні окуляри А чому
тому що дощовик парасоля і чобітки Ми
одягаємо коли тоді коли дощить а сонячні
окуляри Коли нам гаряче і тепло так і
Світить сонечко наступне завдання
Слухайте уважно
дощ
метелик
сніг
сонце
дощ
метелик сніг сонце що тут є зайвим
що тут є зайвим друзі
так молодці метелик є зайвим бо дощ сніг
та сонце це про що
поди дуже добре І останнє друзі будьте
уважні з нашого попереднього заняття
йогурт
сир
печиво молоко
йогурт сир
печиво молоко що тут є зайвим це
завдання є складнішим адже все про що ми
говоримо це є їжа але три
продукти з цієї їжі об'єднує щось одне і
Хто дивився наші попередні заняття точно
знає
Так друзі молодці зайвим є печиво А що
об'єднує йогурт сир та молоко
так малюки молоко їх всіх об'єднує яке
дає корова пригадуєте ми з вами раніше
вчили дуже добре ви великі молодці
А ми давайте з вами далі
продовжуємо говорити про хмарки і я вас
зараз друзі навчу яке ми різними бувають
хмаринки
і ви тепер будете знати Наступного разу
коли будете
наприклад гуляти і дивитися на небо Отож
друзі дивимося на Наші перші хмаринки
цих хмаринки називаються
куб давайте разом повторимо купчасті
бачите вони такі у блакитному небі
купками маленькими кубками збираються і
називаємо їх купчасті
[музика]
так Добре давайте ми
повішаємо
наступні хмаринки
купчасто дощові
купчасту дощові ці хмаринки раніше теж
були купчасті але їх стало так багато і
там зібралося так багато води що вони
стали купчасто дощовими як правило ці
хмаринки купчасті та купчасту дощові
знаходяться дуже низько над землею і
через те Вони мають такий цікавий вигляд
неначе вата тому що нижче біля землі є
тепліше і тут є багато краплинок як і
льоду так і води
наступні хмаринки ця
перисті
перисті хмаринки А знаєте чому користі
бо вони легенькі неначе перо неначе
пір'ячко якоїсь пташки
Вони знаходяться дуже високо над землею
і через те що високо в повітрі і значно
холодніша і є маленькі кристалики льоду
і ці паристі хмаринки виглядають наче
хтось знаєте
мазком білої фарби Ось так взяв
пензликом та й розмалював кілька таких
шарів хмаринок так далі Які в нас
хмаринки
останні на сьогодні
називаються
шаруваті
шаруваті хмари інколи друзі ми їх
плутаємо з сірим небом і просто кажемо о
яке сіренебо а насправді це не сіре небо
це шаруваті хмарки вони просто зна це
дуже низько їх дуже багато і вони
повністю закривають нам небо і
виглядають неначе Таке сіре небо Ось так
друзі шаруваті хмарки так малюки Тепер
ви знаєте як утворюється хмарка які вони
бувають звідки береться і куди дівається
вода у світі і я думаю нам вже пора
закінчувати наше заняття і гукати Совеня
Давайте зробимо таку трубку з рук дві
руки трубку і покличемо Совеня Соня
[музика]
Де ти Де ти Совеня а тут сидить слухай
уважно уявляєте
Та тут я Я слухав заняття про хмарки мої
улюблені паристі хмарки а ваші друзі які
розкажіть мені
так Гаразд супер Ну що ж будемо
прощатися Я був дуже радий вас бачити
па-па малюки
па-па друзі скоро зустрінемось
[музика]
Привіт друзі Всім привіт з вами
науковиця Соломія та Катя Сьогодні ми
експериментуємо і Дивіться що у нас є що
у нас є
в нас є вода
олія
барвники склянка
пензлик і сіль можемо будемо щось
готувати
все щоб готувати дитину але пензлики
склянки
зараз будемо знати Отож перше що нам
треба це налити трішки води гісто
наливай
наливаємо водичку в склянку я скажу
колосок
Добре давай ще
стоп добре так тепер до води ми додаємо
червоний колір
та трішки
червоного барвника
можна ще якийсь колір Та звичайно можемо
бути якийсь інший колір давай їстинку
розмішую яким хочеш
такий гарний червоний так далі
ми
додаємо олію
повільно
так олія додала давайте ще трішки додамо
щоб друзі краще бачили що відбулося ми
вже схожий експеримент робили так от у
нас розділилася вода та олія через те що
олія є легшою вона піднялася нагору і
плаває на воді але що станеться якщо ми
зараз це все посипемо сіллю давайте
подивимось
дуже цікаво так цікаво
що падає
дощ дивіться сніг завдяки тому що
сіль є важчою ніж олія
сіль в тому числі опускає на дно і олію
але коли сіль на дні розчиняється
олія повертається назад
Бачиш юстинку
слово сніг падає це ніби сніг падає так
давайте ми весьмо всю сіль падає ура
бачите олія опускається на низу а потім
піднімається нагору вона не запускається
завдяки тому що сіль є важкою і це
знаєте якби ми додаткову вагу на щось
чіпляємо і воно тягне вниз завдяки чому
завдяки всеві тяжіння А коли сіль падає
на дно і там трохи розчиняється у воді
олія знову відчуває крила так Бо нічого
її не тягне вниз і піднімається нагору
ось такий простий експеримент друзі
можете спробувати вдома але Разом з
дорослими Добре Добре
домовились Ну що ж сьогодні будемо
прощатися Гарного дня па-па
[музика]